you
situational black people in this country
well you know I started becoming
involved in movement for a sort of
desegregation and racial equality when I
moved south in 1956 to teach it black
women's college in Atlanta Georgia
Spelman College I became involved in
movement so that was in 1956 so here we
are just about 50 years later and
talking about the trajectory well we
have gone from a tightly segregated
society in the south and a partially
segregated society in the north to a
more open society not a fully integrated
Society but certainly the South has
changed legal segregation which existed
is over we are seeing more black people
and white people doing things together
there's more intermarriage which is
course there people feared but which is
a good thing which you come to think of
it Obama represents in a good way this
progress has been made
there's now perhaps 1020 percent of the
black population which is economically
much better off than ever has been true
of that part of the black population
before there are more openings in media
and business in the professions for a
certain number of black people but I
speak about 10 or 20 percent for the
vast majority of black people their
lives are still constricted by poverty
and racism so the civil rights movement
accomplished a good deal by beginning to
remove of some of the important social
barriers what it did not remove was the
barrier of class the barrier of economic
injustice Martin Luther King recognized
this
that's why toward the end of his life he
he began
looking for economic rights for black
people so the trajectory is one which
took a very sharp upturn in the 1960s
and which then has us you might say
settle down into a situation which is
not going to change very much until
there's a change in the economic system
of this country so long as we have an
economic system based on profit and
corporate wealth there's going to be an
impoverished class and so long as there
as an impoverished class I'm talking
about the forty many people don't have
health care the twenty percent of the
children in the country who grow up very
very poor so long as we have an
impoverished class black people will be
disproportionately in that class so the
trajectory has reached a point where it
is not going to go up much further
unless we have economic changes which
benefit not just black people but white
people fundamental change and our
economic and social system
let those changes have to be a for the
government to go back and look at what
the New Deal did in the 1930s the New
Deal was not constrained as governments
are today by this idea of old government
must not take a hand in the economy
which is a hypocritical remark anyway
because the government takes a hand in
the economy all the time it just took a
big hand in the economy to help the
financial institutions when I say going
back to the New Deal the principle that
the government must take care of people
the government has to guarantee jobs to
everybody because private enterprise
won't do it has not been able to do it
the government has to guarantee decent
housing for everybody and which again
private enterprise cannot do the
government has to get rid of
privatization in the health system
guarantee free medical care for
everybody what is called a single-payer
system these are the things that the
that need to be done if we are going to
have an egalitarian and Justin humane
society for people of all races
you